a forests
[Applause]
a forest burst into flames but it's
climate change the liberal blames yeah
the oak fire destroyed more than 100
homes and 20 000 acres in the Yosemite
National Forest or Yosemite
it occurred last July just days after it
started with very little known about its
cause liberals were quick to blame it on
global warming I'm surprised it wasn't
racism Trump or gluten
one Senate nitwit tweeting worsening
drought and severe weather will only
continue to put lives and property at
risk from Wildfire if we don't take
climate action now and here's Al Gore
three days after it sparked jabbering on
about the end of the world
more people will be killed and the
survival of our civilization is at stake
that's why the heat records are being
broken uh all the time now that's why
the storms are stronger why the ice is
melting and the sea levels rising and
why the droughts and fires are are
hitting us so hard and so many other
consequences he loves the planet so much
he's starting to look like one but turns
out it wasn't climate change at all nope
it was this guy a former firefighter and
Democratic donor Edward wackerman
oh man that must have been a great last
name growing up
he was arrested just last week on arson
charges wackerman reportedly donated
more than 1700 to democratic candidates
in committees since 2020 and he gave 400
bucks to the Lincoln project you know
it's the group of creepy never trumpers
just look at them
they're like the most pathetic row of
strip club customers ever
you imagine being a lady looking down at
that
just slit my wrists
but it looks like wackerman was right
about the threat of global warming he
just left out the part where he was the
one holding the matches
and that was met with silence Joe
perhaps anticipating something you might
say that would bring laughter to their
hearts
I I hope so Greg I'll tell you what
though
there you go
I knew you could do it
Greg uh you're saying everything is
caused by climate change it's it's
emotional manipulation to scare people
into making them to do what you want and
it's wrong but it's a
it's a good strategy I use it whenever I
ask a woman out I I say that if they say
no that I'll kill myself
[Laughter]
I'm just joking they still say no
do you ever try to trick them with a
call later that you're saying I'm dead
if you hear this phone call I'm dead I
am dead this phone call was recorded and
then you drive around their house like
six times you ever do that
no but I have
I have followed them home yes
and then you say ah I'm not really dead
you want to still go out with me
no I say I was following someone else
who also lives in your home
[Music]
Fair bringing up the donors history when
in fact it's that kind of history that
causes people like him to go crazy over
the climate the whole climate issue so
maybe he deserves it
would say you well I think that first
the way some of peop some people have
talked about climate issues the fact
that it appears to have been an arson
situation I don't think that they would
say okay it still could be climate
because of what you said because he is
so upset about the climate or how many
times have we heard that people are
doing bad things because of climate
change exactly we've heard we've heard
that already so they've kind of covered
all their bases yeah it's true nothing
that can ever not be climate change if
everything is it's just like the Kev
it's like the Kevin Bacon of issues
right Six Degrees of Separation this is
just now two degrees of separation
climate change didn't cause the fires it
caused the guy anxiety that led to him
starting the fires so he still took two
steps to get back to climate or three if
you count Uh Kevin Bacon playing a
fireman
only most people don't talk about this
right it's already people have already
made up their minds that it was the
climate and they're not even going to
think about this or address it that is
true KT isn't this is this the correct
definition of the word ironic
hmm or is it a hip I was gonna say
hypocrite hypocrite's a better word much
better word but you know Al Gore who
talks about climate change all the time
he's been talking about what 20 years
ago he said that the polar ice caps
would be all melted
um within the decade and then you have
Greta thundberg and she's saying you
know don't even have children because
the world's going to be over by then
today was supposed to be I think today
was the day it was supposed to end I do
believe so what are we doing here I have
no idea this could all be a hologram and
we could all we are oh no no
generative AI we're all artificial yeah
exactly I know I am I'm as fake as they
come by the way
while far at the wildfires in Canada
everybody was telling me that they're
started by arsonists and like there's
I'm pretty certain most of them are and
I did research by doing none
Jamie oh I'm sorry
what did you wanna it turns out you know
that was the first thing everybody said
those Canadian wildfires were all going
blind Greg don't go out of your hosts
you're gonna die
um and it turns out that it wasn't
global warming it was because of the
environmentalists who weren't letting
them yeah you know burn the underground
there were also some crazy people that
were lighting the fire well yeah Jamie
it's got to be hard living in Alaska and
being an arsonist what have you done to
somehow change your interests in Hobbies
yeah the the match just keeps going out
um
the only good thing is those Canadian
fires only burn 70 as intense as the
American that joke didn't work because
of climate change
did you see in this article that the
headline of this article it said that it
was a ginormous Inferno it would be
totally honest I did not know ginormous
was a real word yeah I didn't know is
that I have not heard that word since
this one time I took my penis out at the
park
[Laughter]
seriously this cop was like hey you're
going to get a ginormous fine for that
tiny thing
there you go and by the way Greg you
know in these troubling times sometimes
I uh record some advice that I like to
share please
[Music]
lessons tips from a divorced dad
hey kids do you know what the strongest
part of your body is
your brain
so give it a workout and think of a
really believable excuse to skip school
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else